greetings from podcast Ville it's
Thursday March 2nd they kicked this
[__] melee
[Music]
murky waters today my main man is he at
least sigh yeah hello I want to talk to
you guys about a couple things you know
we're going through tough times right
now it's kind of funny I was thinking
about what I told you guys there that
I'm back on a prison schedule and it's
so weird because I've been through this
something that makes you change your
life it's a strong thing and I've been
through this before three [__] times
I've been through three life changes in
my life one when my mother died which
was similar to this this is why I have
the same feeling as my stomach as if
somebody died because life as we know it
has died number two when I went to
prison and number three when I got
divorced so after a while you start
learning how to cover your ass when I
went to prison I spent all my money on
the attorney I had a little bit of money
put away on the side to take care of
myself while I was in prison but I knew
that money wouldn't end I had to do
something while I was in prison to make
money and the third one is when I went
and got divorced I lost my job because
you guys forget I work for my wife
I work for my wife's family there were
my brother-in-law's they paid me great
money but once I got separated they made
some excuse up ah they got slow and they
went to Jersey and picked up a job in
other words telling me to go [__] myself
with what which left me with my dick in
my hand which is going on right now
right now you're feeling like you're
left with your dick in your hand like
everybody's feeling like Jesus Christ
what the [__] is my next move well I'll
tell you what man
this is why I wanted to talk to you
about this today because I was thinking
after I said it I got in the car then I
got a couple emails about it and it's
true now is it time to reinvent yourself
in a [__] weird way when I went to
prison I was scared the way we are right
now we're always scared in the beginning
like what's gonna happen once it settles
them with you which it has with a lot of
years I hope that this is settled with
you I hope that you still think that the
digital Cheney's smuggle that listen
whatever happened it doesn't matter
whatever
at this point our lives are [__]
change that's all we know right now
we're in the house some of us lost our
jobs some of us are waiting front of
employment some of us awaiting for the
stimulus check but I told you the other
day I go listen go over the [__] your
supermarket and apply for a job some guy
wrote back I got a job but they only
want to pay me in 960 that's 960 you
wouldn't have got before you know if
they [__] up your unemployment then I
wouldn't take it either I wouldn't take
it either I swallowed it three weeks and
sit at home but for right now while
you're waitin even 960 an hour with some
overtime is a lot better than some
hazard pay there's a lot better than
[__] sitting at home but anyway when
I got locked up you know you got one
inside and here I'm still used to
wheeling and dealing every day and in
those days I sold cars and I worked for
a roof I had a thousand things but guys
I always wheeled in deal I always had
somebody calling me going hey I don't
know I feel weird asking me do you know
I can get an ounce of coke no not really
yeah I know I hey it's Thursday you know
I get a hundred [__] sleeping pills
no I don't know yeah I [__] know you
know do you know why you get a machine
gun yeah I know you know I was one of
those type of guys I did felony favors I
charge you 20% that's what it's called
it's called the felony favor and you
know before I went to jail I was doing
for free like I would help yeah I get it
I'll get your bazooka if you wanna kill
your mother I don't give a [__] I will
get you the bazooka because I need
different people so different things so
you know I'm the type of guy if I'm
gonna make it if I can make a [__]
doll I'm making a [__] dollar that's
how it was raised that's that's what
living day-to-day is so when I got
locked up I didn't know what the [__] to
do what you can't do nothing right you
can't do nothing you got locked up I was
involved in the first day and then they
sent me to [__] Summit County Jail
and they told me I was gonna be there
for three months I ended up being there
for like [__] seven eight days and I
went right the Canyon City to get
[__] processed processing took five
days you wait another three or four days
and some [__] in the ward way or some
[__] I waited and then they took me to
camp Georgia they took me to [__] in
camp George West I get the camp George
yes I think I'd like $38 you allowed to
have money in your pocket because you
were allowed to go to the store for 20
minutes that has to change by now right
yeah no now they don't let you out of
the [__] building problem and I mean
the money yeah they don't let you but
then they let you have cash in your
pocket you can have up to $30 or $40 or
something like that because you could go
to the store every day in the mornings
when you wake up you just sign up to go
to the store and they'd let you walk you
could see you walk from the prison all
the way there storing all the way back
so it was no big thing it was like a
block and a half and it was good for you
you got to go out and exercise a little
bit so you know I get the [__] prison
I don't know what I got on my books
hundred dollars whatever some friend
sent me money like you know when I got
locked up some people put money on my
books and [__] but I knew that she would
end
I like the [__] you know how I do mo
at that point I was in the fat slug but
at night you get bored in prison you
don't even need edibles tea you get
bored it's [__] you gotta eat you know
so I get the I get the prison I gotta
figure out how to make a buck so first I
started out as a baker a baker was like
a dirty five cents an hour thirty five
cents an hour they pay you to be a
[__] baker and I had to work like all
these [__] hours i think i purposely
blew up the i made cinnamon buttons but
I made them really big and they almost
blew up the [__] oven and they got
really big so the guy was like dog you
don't know what you're doing I got tried
to tell you that when you didn't even
[__] ask me like did you ever get
hepatitis hepatitis no I said so now
that was my prerequisite was [__] do
you ever get hepatitis No hi so I'm in
the [__] kitchen blowing up ovens
this [__] Darvin goes on fire one
morning he calls me the guys name was
mr. Yarborough this guy was six foot six
what do you want to do big black and
bold I mean this guy was just big he
made Patrice O'Neal God rest his soul
looks like a [__] [__] really oh
this guy was big
black he was in the Navy for 90 years he
had just retired mr. Yarborough black
and he would yell and [__] and call you
stupid I don't want to know what he did
ago and he would torture black people
because he hated Negroes he was like one
of those black people that hated black
people from being in the service like he
hated worthless black people and guys
the dreadlocks is [__] so he would
torment them from the kitchen guys he
tormented his own black people more on
the white dudes like he was such a navy
guy so mr. Yarborough cut me a deal he
was man I got to get some help with this
stock and nobody knows how to do it I
had a guy that was in here for like
[__] four years and he had the job
down to a science
I go what's that job pay he goes a
dollar 35 or now oh and I'm like oh [__]
and how much do you make how many hours
a week cuz I'll give you 40 but he goes
you only work my two hours a day you got
to come in of course you fall into this
work oh right off the [__] two days in
the [__] joint
you gotta button my mouse I have a
license I also have a high school
diploma I was also going and got ending
a college when I got arrested all these
things were happening not not to be rude
was it a real diploma or was a fake one
what did you lie about the or did you
have your GED I had my genes okay after
I got arrested I wouldn't got my GED
okay so I got my GED in between me
getting on bail and me getting arrested
and me getting sentence I'm sorry I got
my GED got into the university Colorado
legitimately and was about to start
classes for the Fall remember I got
sentenced August 15
so I get named making a buck 35 an hour
forty hours a week but I'm really
working to I gotta go in early in the
morning I gotta wait for the [__]
shipments of meat and bread and milk and
all that [__] and then at 4:00 I gotta
go check out and make sure they got
everything like I gotta go
at 4:30 before they start dinner and go
do you guys need vegetables whatever
they need and have to bring it over on a
wheel cart that was a long [__] walk
but I didn't give a [__] at burn time
you
I was trying to get in shape trying to
stay in shape yeah but I knew that a
dollar 35 is a dollar thirty five times
forty dollars I don't know what it came
out there 40 something dollars or some
[__] I wasn't getting [__] rich but I
wasn't doing drugs either so I figured
out that if I want to they had a Chinese
restaurant next to the deli oh right so
I'm like I want a back one day and I go
does anybody ever get Chinese food and
they're like yeah sometimes but nobody
really like nobody really has the money
for Chinese food I'm like how much is
[__] Chinese rice it was at that time
it was 250 for a pint
damn so I would bring a pint of Chinese
rice back I would call it and nobody
figured out how to do it to call it in
and go I'll be there one [__] 15 make
sure that rice is ready I'm coming from
the prison across the street and the
lady we go okay we wait and I was run
over there I get whatever I had to the
Chinese place is right next to the store
so run into the store get milk eggs
whatever I need it for that night but
let's get to that so at first I would
just buy like bags of chips you know
maybe another guy didn't want to go out
maybe you didn't want to go out but you
know you were broke and I brought you
something back to make your day I was
one of those guys so I'm making a buck
35 and I'm like this ain't gonna [__]
work this just ain't gonna [__] work
and I've become friends with a mafia
dude a fat little mafia dude until his
dad came him what his [__] name is
I've tried real hard and he used to cook
every day every day he would cook from a
[__] he would take the inside of an
iron and make spaghetti sauce with
stewed tomatoes and make spaghetti he
knew all the brothers in the kitchen so
he would make spaghetti for them and
they'd cut a deal so I tapped into him
he came to me one day Nero's dog what do
you got for supplies in the back do you
have any cheese I'll make nachos for us
so I started getting them [__] cheese
from the kitchen Steelman right and I
cut him a deal like I bring you the
cheese I get two orders of nachos nice
nice boom so I started with two things
our nachos
at least I got the nachos okay so every
night add nachos your quarters every
night every [__] night I would give
him [__] but there were little orders
okay you think this is [__] positive
Mason I don't know this is just a little
is a little white dude that made nachos
with cheese and he put jalapenos in it
something with [__] drink it with so
does this [__] there was a soda machine
so when they figured out I go you're a
[__] Savage I go why don't I bring
you like white bread and you can make
grilled cheese sandwiches on the stove
nice so he started making a grilled
cheese sandwich so I would sell him 50
cents and we split the [__] money he
also ran a bookmaking operation he had
like one he would run numbers you know
those cards those betting slips right
where you [__] have the boxes mm-hmm
like I never did that before in my life
I never even knew what a box was I swear
to God like people put yeah yeah they do
for the Super Bowl we were doing it for
everything oh damn no he was doing it
for football okay okay so I came along
and I'm like you're doing this for
football and I go how do you do with
this and he goes if I fill up one card
it's a lot because I can't get through
the other guys a lot of the inmates
don't like me I go well [__] I run the
[__] kitchen anything that has to go
down me so I got the brothers the
kitchen was just eight black guys and
two white dudes I still remember the
other white dude I still think about him
because he was very scared he was a rich
white kid that got drunk and killed
somebody no no they're not gonna do you
I in 1987 and he was serving six years
for manslaughter and he was scared so I
kind of took care he was a nice white
kid he was funny he was dorky and the
and the brothers liked him so he had
protection nobody's gonna [__] him in
the ass and done like that it was fine
so for me I would take that I asked him
one day I go can I get a shot at selling
these cards cuz I could talk to the
Mexican I basically made yourself a
partner I could talk to the black guys I
would go on the [__] laundry room the
black guys would be playing dominoes
listen the [__]
don't be cruel by Bobby Brown you think
I'm [__] kidding you that was the
album of the [__] year was Bobby
Brown solo album so they would be in
their [__] I give me cause diamond
rings I just about giving you everything
all that [__] they be [__] jumpin up
and down and be twenty black guys in
there so they needed food too so I
started I that the leader of the black
dudes worked in the kitchen
his name was Chicken Hawk and he was
pretty much in charge of the [__]
kitchen his nemesis was graveyard Oh a
black guy that they called graveyard he
had he had his own troupe of black dudes
and where's mr. Yarborough mr.
Yarborough is in the kitchen he's not
supervisor in the kitchen he's in charge
of the kitchen so the two gangs we had
in the joint were Chicken Hawk from
Louisiana and then his nemesis his enemy
was graveyard this black dude that that
used to walk around with an afro and a
[__] is picking an afro house so I
didn't [__] around with graveyard too
much I I [__] around with Chicken Hawk
and then the other black dude I [__]
it was the [__] he was a [__] a
stone-cold [__] I think he was a rollin
[__] I'm not sure I don't want to say
something that's incorrect well the
other [__] there's another side of [__]
from the rampart Crips I think there's
like a gang over there and he was in
charge of delivering cocaine from LA to
Colorado but we're getting ahead of
ourselves so me and the Italian dude I
swear the guy's God when I got together
with him like the second week of
September he was moving one car the
night I came into the operation during
football season we did two cards on
Monday Night Football and probably 10
cards on Sunday Saturday college
football we'd do 10 [__] card and
once basketball came I really got the
troops going brothers loved basketball
and we would make Denver Nuggets so
guess what bro
I started making 40 60 70 dollars and
then I did my greatest [__] trick of
all time guys but now you're thinking
like Joey how did you come up with these
schemes I didn't I didn't
right the book on these schemes hunger
motivated me I was forced the same way
we're getting forced right now to switch
careers and switch jobs and think of
what else is next and think of what our
next move is it's the same thing I was
facing in 88 when I got locked up it's
no different that's why I've accepted
this for what the [__] it is you take
this you take this whatever you strength
is right now you [__] attack it and
you you know you just have to work all
[__] strength that's it I don't give
a [__] what they tell you to get through
this thing that we got right now you
gotta go in there like a [__] animal
now I'm not I'm not proud of these
things I did but I had to eat and I had
to stay alive and this is what you do to
safar to survive this is what you need
to do remember I always tell people I
know what you gotta do this is what you
need to do because if not I wouldn't got
eaten up alive in that well cuz it's
something that you've said from the
beginning it's like you can't go the way
everyone else is going because like
those online job postings now that were
terrible before this happened everyone
in the country is home looking at those
way yeah now forget about all that
just go to your local supermarket and
stock shelves at night for right now
until at least you have a [__] job
yeah you get a mass like I got on right
[__] now I got a mask on right
[__] now why it's bad out there this
is the week it's gonna get bad these
next two weeks are gonna be crucial next
Sunday we'll be doing a podcast I'll
zoom we'll be doing a podcast on zoom
because my wife our landlord died on
Friday so he got on Monday and he died
on Friday out here I don't know where he
lived
I know glendale's got a high amount or
whatever but I really yeah I'm not here
to talk to you people we've been I don't
want to talk about this [__] let's talk
about how we could get ahead all right
so what's the greatest disappearing act
I did two disappearing acts in Colorado
they all make you [__] fall of each
chair while I'm doing all this [__]
that's what opens up a job for a [__]
jailhouse attorney do you have to be a
lawyer like the house to protect people
when they get in trouble right but her
any requirements acquirement should I
take a test to know all the
rules of the prison system okay and then
with your intelligence you could
whatever and you had to go in there with
your defendant and fight from OSHA so
like two months in I applied for that
job and I got it all the way from Baker
the lawyer that was already another
forty bucks
it was like a dollar ten an hour so I'm
like [__] I got two jobs I'm Joey two
jobs in jail I'm a [__] kitchen stop
calling every job oh you're [__] yeah I
kept it I'm a workaholic
you know man got time to [__] sit in
my [__] room and stare at the ceiling
and think about what could have been I
don't want that type of luxury at 25 at
25 you weren't gonna get me at office
today you were still making the minimum
wage oh then I always thought I didn't
give a [__] I didn't give a [__] no I
just wanted to make money so now I did
my biggest disappearing trick I'm
sitting there one day and I like I said
let's just say this guy's name was John
Clark [__] it who cares it was okay was
out of Philly if he's still alive god
bless you
cuz I love you at all my heart you bad
white [__] John Clark had killed
the dude in Philly and he was just some
badass white dude okay he was an Irish
badass white dude didn't even look Irish
he looked like something out of a [__]
like a killer movie he just had that
personality he had just been done he was
in his last two years of a 16-year
sentence he was an interesting guy he
was a part of people who hate you know
black people and Jews Aaron banished
people but him too
had some juvenile because he did
business with me so that's just to show
you I don't care if you hate white black
green purple
no I don't care have you heard I don't
care if you hurt I've you if you hate
brown you know whatever color Jews art
and whatever color green Chinese people
you always loved the color green so John
Clark was a dude you just can't that's
another thing like you people who would
like there's people who just invite
themselves on the podcast
he like in prison you get smacked for
inviting yourself like I could never
come up to you and go a leak and I talk
to you for a second I have a proposal
for you can I do this and this and that
and they look at you like you don't even
know me the next time you disrespect me
I'm gonna knock the [__] buddy
that's how real it is so how you
supposed to do it there's a way that do
things okay
one way is to show up how you show up
you gotta show up with an envelope yeah
so he was pretty much in charge of the
Arians and he talked to me
when I got locked up it was the Aryans
they hung out by themselves then you had
the bikers that hung up by themselves we
could all [__] them up there their
leader I forget what his [__] [__] he
[__] name was he was a bikers I hate
it at that time I was mad at bikers
because the guy who ratted on me was a
bike so I had seen through the whole
facade so now I get locked up and
there's this this [__] biker crew in
there and the low guy on the totem pole
always thought he was tough and I [__]
him up before I got out but before we
got put his piece of [__] in his drawer
I took his [__] and put an American
cheese box and putting his drawer but
let's not get to this so I'm making the
40 bucks a week from the [__] from
the being the attorney at the jail right
and I'm a [__] upscale convict
like I'm upscale like people like oh my
god you're doing such a great job of
about me while I'm gambling I'm
promoting gambling I'm inciting gambling
because every card I sold I made 20
bucks and then not like let it go too
far away is this also at the point when
you're doing the acid you were talking
about yeah so we were also doing acid
like on Sunday nights me Jesus Barry
anatoray pal we were all do an acid on
Sunday nights not every Sunday just some
Sunday's Sundays we did acid on Sundays
because it was the Simpsons it was not
the Simpsons laughs you know lost an
marriage okay yeah whatever it is for
you it was that it was America's in
prison everybody watches America's Most
Wanted oh yeah every night stop on
Sunday night and that show
first came out when I was locked up in
88 that's what you watch you couldn't
even talk during America's Most Wanted
cuz there was always one guy that said I
know that dude yeah right so there was
always one dude who said that so not
only was an attorney and or whatever so
now there's a hole in the system I'm not
doing drugs but I know who's doing drugs
at that time there was one - there was
like maybe seven or eight you know army
barracks okay that they converted into
prisons and I knew was doing drugs there
was like three barracks that would they
were there together because they were
heroin heads and I and there was meth
heads there wasn't calling meth back
there they called it speed and there was
a little guards were breaking it
innocently no so there was two ways
there's one way to bring in drugs okay
and that's the girl puts the balloon
filled with heroin she the swallows at
like three days before and shits it off
in the jail there's a thousand ways all
there is to check that puts it in a
[__] takes the balloon out of a [__]
puts it in her mouth makes out with you
and then you [__] the balloon out okay
okay so they always search you on the
way back from visitation but there was
one way that I knew you could get drugs
in I had heard about it but I had the
magic answer how to do it you ever
driving around and you go on 101 or 405
when they're your routes and you see
guys picking up papers uh-huh
okay that's how you smuggling drugs into
prison okay okay so I figured out a way
the reason why I had to go there early
in the morning was to give them the
supplies they would give me what they
needed for the menu so I would walk and
get everything they needed meat potatoes
ten pounds of garlic whatever they
needed I would get it from the stock
bring it back and then my second job was
to get a crate three crates of lunches
and I will put them in the back
with two-wheel drive Toyota truck a
little long bed truck and I would drive
it to a different location so I would
drive it to a different location
we're picking up trash what's that
wherever they're picking up trash
wherever they were picking up trash so
he would tell me that morning at 7:30
when I went to pick up whatever he would
tell me hey do you know how to get to I
70 in this street they're gonna be
working over on the whatever side of the
road today Wow so the first couple times
I did it I didn't really think anything
of it you know I'm saying I didn't think
everything of it and then one day I go
what am i doing this is money so even
they believing you know about using that
information what do you mean leaving Wow
[__] leave what are you [__] why
would I leave I'm not leaving I knew
where we were gonna they were gonna be
that morning right so what I would do is
I would run over to the back he wouldn't
tell me where I was going I would run
over to the back and then I would go to
John Clark and tell him where they were
going John Clark would walk around the
back to a black kids
give him his girlfriend's number and a
quarter and that guy would get on the
pay phone call John Clark's girlfriend
and tell him where to meet John Clark
while he was picking up God so she would
go and throw a balloon out and put it in
like a baggie so when he was picking up
stuff he knew exactly where to go and
pick up the bag sometimes he would
swallow the balloon or I would wait for
him at the gate
and talk to the guard and they wouldn't
be searched Wow
and every day you would do this three
days a week so I would either do it with
John Clark or this Mexican kid that's
crazy
see you for jobs in prison I'm pretty
happy that was my biggest moneymaker
cuz John Clark was giving me like 100
bucks a week Wow
so what were like how did you hide all
this money cuz Dini say you only have 40
bucks and I would hide it in my storage
oh I would hide it in the storage there
was a tree close to the storage so I dug
up this thing by the tree so it wasn't
really on my property but it was they
couldn't come to me and I also had
steroids there and drugs so I charged a
Vig on that also now when in my life was
I sitting there gone when I go to prison
I know exactly what I'm gonna do right
never I didn't know this I thought I'd
always go to prison but I didn't even
know these opportunities were there this
is the same thing that's going on now
with us we don't know what's gonna
happen to the smoke clears once the
smoke cleared I went to work did I ever
dream of being the jailhouse attorney
yeah I mean that's all our dreams we all
wake up every morning going you know
what I think I'm gonna go to prison so I
could be a jailhouse attorney you know
none of us have that [__] dream but
this is what I had to create from my
setback
well you said something on the last
podcast and stuck with me and you're
like oh but Joey I want to be a
ballerina whatever you said okay well
that's over for now well you gotta do
what you gotta do for now because now
we're told there's no ballerina it's not
necessarily like forever no there's no
ballerina and then and I think that's
one of the hardest or one of the things
that you learn coming out of college is
that it's not just up it's not just oh
you get what better job and a better job
and a better job and then
you're CEO by the time inserting in a
mansion is you're gonna lose a job or
you're gonna have to move or your
parents get sick it's there's downs to
it to this all and you have to adjust
you have to adapt life was not given to
you that's what problems with people are
they a lot of people are scared of the
future right now which they should be
which they should be they have no no no
I'm not trying to scare people I'm
trying to be honest it here if you don't
think I'm scared I'm scared I'm scared
for my daughter I'm scared for my
friends I'm scared for my family I'm
scared for you guys what's gonna happen
you're gonna lose your houses do you
lose your cars do you lose your lives
what happens I'm scared I'm scared also
what's gonna happen after this I there's
a big difference between somebody me
taking a week off and somebody telling
me I can't do comedy
but in my mind this is the way I'm
thinking about Tommy right now I'm
thinking about economy in the way is
it's better to quit ahead than just
quitting like I know that Tommy is out
of my life for about six months
Wow it's not just you know I'll go back
to it but going back to the prison thing
you know here I was the jailhouse
attorney but at the same time I was also
helping two guys bring drugs in for them
to make money and then give me a piece
of the action
when I got out of prison I think the dag
on had like 900 bucks cash and then they
gave me like 180 or something to go to
the halfway house the state gives you a
check for 180 I showed up at the halfway
house like with a thousand bucks like
what the [__] going on they go you
can't walk around with more than 40
bucks in your pocket and I'm my client I
just started a bank account but when I
came out of prison I came out with my
that's great that's crazy that's great
and then it's not money I mean it was
$900 negative yeah no it's better than
way better than being negative and yet I
remember I was buying Chinese food every
day every day every day every day I was
eating like a
but I was also running I was lifting I
was walking around that [__] place I
was 25 years old right I took up jogging
in prison and it carried out for maybe a
year and a half after I got out I jogged
every day and that's I said I got
bursitis in my heels and that's what
ended it my running career
from getting the Spurs and my heels and
a natural would hurt my feet but when I
got did when I got in prison I was not
lazy at all
there was no way first of all you have
black-and-white TVs except in the age
unit the age unit has a colored TV every
other TVs a little eight-by-tens
black-and-white I'm not in to watch him
black on my TV you know that [__] you
[__] you I rather [__] watch TV so I
didn't like watching TV in the daytime I
always kept busy man that's the main
thing to do you know I did I was going
into the unknown not knowing the same is
now when I got locked up I didn't know
if I was gonna get out in february/march
a year they sent me the four years I
wanted to the unknown not know when I
got in there I also discovered house
rule 1440 which says first time offender
non-violent your sentence gets cut in
half I'm the one who sent that to my
attorney in my tiny notes I knew about I
wasn't it put up for the appeal that was
your appeal was about but I had already
found all that stuff out on my own once
I got locked up but the point of this
whole story I just told you was that
when I got in there
nobody knew nothing I didn't know these
opportunities are gonna be available to
me saw my son fell in my lap and some I
created as creepy as they sound well and
that [__] didn't even stop it did it
carried over when I got to the halfway
house guess what I became in the halfway
house what a loanshark because nobody
gets paid till Friday but they want
their rent on Thursday they do it to you
on purpose so you won't have the rent so
you can't go out for the weekend they
did that to you on purpose
so they wanted you to be at one ahead so
usually it took people like four months
to get one ahead
pay up the week ahead and then now they
pay on fighting I'm saying something
like they didn't give a [__]
they made that rule for a purpose so you
didn't have to go out on the weekend
yeah well that's why they made that rule
when there's a broker Joey comes in I
come in I give you the 75 but you gotta
give me back 105 for one day it's 20
bucks 25 bucks for one day loan I had
ten of those guys I yeah that's
definitely skillet I was even before you
brought this up today I was thinking
about uh Josh wolf when he was young and
had had the peanut butter and jelly
delivery service look if you ever wanted
to do something with food now's the time
to do it all that but there was a
problem there because he had to get a
kitchen right no that [__] the idea was
great I mean the idea was great that
Josh had but that's what this is you you
getting put your gettin a gun put to
your head and told what to do how to
earn in a minimal amount of time right
what do you think you have to you know
so I don't want nobody that at home
listening to this to think that you're
[__] stuck in any way you have options
I'm not saying [__] I didn't tell you
this stories he he go out and [__]
smuggle weed or or whatever the [__]
we're talking about here
I'm telling you this story so you know
that this is the same situation I went
through in 1988 I've gone through the
situation three times like I tell you
when my mother died I had to figure it
out when I went to prison I had to
figure it out and then when I got
divorced I had a figure it the [__] out
when I got divorced I got the worst in
91 which made me 28 years old right
before I got caught I got into comedy I
knew nothing about nothing I knew how to
[__] work I know how to make a little
bit of money but I didn't know anything
about the real world when that woman
left me my [__] life was shattered
and if anybody who's been left by a wife
or broken up with a wife or something
like that
I mean you a ball with something
different that's boyfriend and
girlfriend
no I'm talking about when you're married
you have a why
you've been through hell for six years
or seven years and and then I had to be
[__] let loose
it was rough then it was rough at first
you know and again
guess what I did gonna become a neon
salesman and I started making money with
Nia cuz I put my mind to it so what did
that entail I had a do you think I ever
oh yeah I woke up when I was eight years
old one day and said oh when I get older
I want to sell Nia no it didn't it let
me do comedy then let me do comic I
didn't want to now to get every morning
every day I would wake up and go to
[__] Kinkos when Kinkos was around
this King color still around yeah
vinick's Kinkos I would go to Kinko's in
the morning and I'd make 100 copies or
[__] a sheet of paper and it would be
like this sheet of paper but I would put
it on a [__] a thicker sheet of paper
and I would walk into strip malls and
just hand them to people going to that
place of is how you doing my name is
Joey here take a look at this flyer and
people go thank you
some people throw it away it's like
Mitch Hedberg his joke here you throw
this away yeah it was one of those jokes
but some people look at it and go neon I
was looking for a neon open sign you
know yeah so this is what I'm saying
the-- hold on well I mean I was talking
to our buddy George and he said there's
a lot of cleaning jobs right now like
you never like even though there are
jobs I think there's a lot of stuff
that's open right now no listen if
you're home right now and you're feeling
a little [__] down and you know like
that it's over I don't want you to
[__] yourself life is not gonna be
the same as it was before but I will
tell you one thing that you could make a
difference you could go out there and do
something just to keep the lights on
right now just to keep the lights on to
make yourself feel better to take your
mind off this [__] to take your mind off
this [__] even if it's at night just
going to a supermarket I still want you
to stay home and mind your [__]
business well it's pretty tough to
[__] stay home and just
let the four walls creep around you I'm
here to tell you I'm going through the
same thing that you guys gone through
you know I get out two hours a week to
do the podcast my wife made me war
[__] her master I have not she said
you don't come back she made me [__]
war a mess so you know this is the week
when it's getting serious and next week
so I mean I get it that you don't want
to [__] be bored but you can exercise
in your house it's better than going to
a [__] park and walking behind some
guy that's jogging and he's got it he's
a carrier and you're running right
behind them yeah you're taking care
yourself or you if I see more than five
people I don't go there
in today's world that's what you need to
do you see more than three or four
people you don't want to go there cuz
you know what eventually they're gonna
break the barrier so why [__] around
okay I came out here today and I talked
to you guys
we're going on zoom' next week so for
the next couple see we had guests we had
a tremendous [__] March planned and
we had the beginning of April [__]
tremendously planned but all this [__]
took us down we're back to us I don't
give a [__] you know me I come in here
and tell you guys the truth and bust
your balls for an hour but we're going
to zoom on Sunday so we could start
getting guests again at least local
guests so they don't feel bad
I don't feel bad leaders and feel bad
but at least you guys could keep
entertained and you guys know I got your
back and I love you with all my heart
we're gonna try to keep doing this as
long as they let us you know as long as
the Chi like Lisa don't mean it let her
to drive over you don't need BIC the
cops get behind you just press go tell
make sure you say that I call you Joey
they live there where they arrested me
come get me throw you in jail they gonna
give you a fine
you know I don't want them to give you a
fine but most importantly I didn't want
you to get sick for a stupid move or for
me to get say no I've been on you for
the last two weeks to get healthier to
stop with this [__] coffee and to get
to the bottom of this because we can't
be around each other I have a six year
old and 7 year old and I have my own
responsibilities so from now on
everybody around me I mean I don't want
nobody around me for the next couple of
weeks
stand up I don't know what's happening
you don't know what's happening I don't
have a [__] crystal ball neither do
you so until I know I'll keep you posted
on dates and whatnot listen you're not
alone number one you're not the only one
who's going through this okay
everybody's going through this right now
take a breath then that deep breath look
up be thankful for your life be thankful
they gave you another [__] day and
mind your business don't go out there's
nobody you need to know no no nothing
if you need coffee from Starbucks hang
yourself now stop it you don't need no
[__] coffee from Starbucks you're
going out free essentials okay you're
not going out for don't go to [__] at a
big supermarket do not go to a big
supermarket you cannot be this dumb and
if you go shopping it's at 8:01 at 7:01
got a little side little supermarkets
not like a little hindu market they got
[__] the essentials in there you know
I'm saying yeah they got curry which
you're not gonna buy and hummus which
you're not gonna buy but they got milk
they got bread they got eggs they love
eggs
Hindus love eggs if anybody's got an egg
right now it's the [__] Hindus okay
and I love them you know I ain't mad at
nobody I'm just telling you the truth do
not go to those big chains please do it
for your uncle Joey you know where the
little ones are you drive by them every
day they got these essentials ground
beef is ground beef just don't buy it in
a bat market all right don't buy to the
bat market ground beef is ground beef so
you can still make your [__]
meatballs you can still make your spin
spaghetti sauce you can still do
whatever listen for these next two weeks
I'm trying with all my heart not to get
a fight you know I've been dying without
my [__] burrito my being and beef my
dad being in cheese burrito really I
love it I love beans okay but I can't go
there because there's always there's no
social distancing right and there's
people sitting and eating there so that
scares the [__] out of me I want to
support local people you know I want to
support local people I if you once you
told me you weren't eating out no more
no you're not then I'm not eating out so
I'm trying to support the places like
I'm been craving [__] sushi I'll meet
you
craving sushi more than all you
[__] but do I go no so I don't
want to [__] hear nobody [__]
crying we're gonna deal with the
guylines we're gonna do what the [__]
they tell us to do and that's it and
this all [__] pass I get to live you
get to live your parents get to live
your grandparents get to live this is a
happy ending if you don't [__] stay
home it's only gonna get worse the next
I don't know you hurt I know you missed
disk listen go to liquor store again not
the popular liquor store go to the ones
where the real alcoholics go to you know
the same way you go there you see three
guys fill them out of a lottery ticket
if there's three guys they only have a
lottery ticket you're at the right place
those guys are looking for a payday they
take care of themselves they know a
better day is coming those little
degenerate gamblers right now this is
not a gamble on right so right now
they're just paying the tickets they
just bangin out taking of Vegas you
can't even go to Vegas so you can't even
gamble only my bookie can help you out
with the gamble if you want to play
cards [__] like that they got the online
casino they can help you but I mean
gamble on sports and just typical
gambling and you all that shit's dead
that shit's dead as we know it so so go
to go to the hidden love your store in
front of my place begin that [__] while
I'm trying to do a [__] podcast you
know waving at me like you see I'm
talking into a microphone there way with
uh unbelievable I think this is making
people dumbest [__] this but that's it
and that's that man those are the rules
for the next two weeks we will be back
Monday morning nice and early
I will not [__] leave you guys out to
dry don't do that [__] like I said stand
up I don't know what the [__] going on
I haven't spoken to anybody about that
spoke to Tom Rhodes I spoken to a couple
people I checked in with Dean Delroy
Steve Simone Lee I've spoken to Theo I
spoken to Joe I spoke in the Sam so I've
kept in touch with the troops
everybody's flying on our end I love you
guys
I love you for supporting us and listen
god bless you guys like I said I know
you're hurt
but you gotta keep moving you know I'm
getting anxiety to leave when I came up
here and I have anxiety yes I have
anxiety
it's [__] high but I'm making it
[__] happen okay I want to thank you
guys for supporting us I want you to
thank you for listening and I want to
thank you for being here thank you for
being [__] for your strength thank
you for all those social media love I'm
there every day [__] with you
[__] you know like I told you
yesterday
it's April 2nd Jews are mad today
they're [__] serious my rent my rent
this is you right now [__] burning
down his own building this is the first
time in the history of [__] life I
have the word shooting a 22 [__]
checks on a [__] they're all sitting
there scratching at the worst letter I
got a letter
you know we need our money too so please
pay your right didn't give a [__] they
don't give a [__] about man all of you
here in this [__] there's no man but
there's a man named in there will I said
no [__] eviction so go [__] yourself
you could [__] go on a door knock I
know don't make it a trip up to check-in
throw in her face and go there you go
and then on top of like take some pew
bees and throw them in her eyeball - who
gives a [__] it's a minor assault you
only do you only do four days like John
Jones you know I'm saying I can shoot a
meal and get a DUI and do four days
tremendous I love now he's got four days
of house arrest oh he played the guilty
for to this second DUI third on paper
and he got four days I love John Jones
but they're not doing nothing to help
but that has nothing to do with me you
or anybody else oh we need to take care
of it ourselves right now pray for
themselves and you [__] I love
you to death I'm gonna go home and
Mercer she's gonna hit the pads today
I'm gonna hit the bag together we've
been hitting the bank together she's
strong dude she is strong but I she hits
the pads I hold him for a listen I got a
I got a work her to because she's got
the energy at [__] 10 athletes bro
it's it's it's scary it's tough being a
homeschooler
you know I got to draw a [__] rocket
ship today at some point because she has
to draw an astronaut so trust me
everybody has a rough night now nobody
going through this slowly my wife is
she's not losing it but the death of the
of the property manager hid a little
home with her so I don't want this to
happen any of you guys so please take
care of yourselves I love you thank you
for giving us another week and thank you
for listening you bad [__] stay
home and mind your business all right
I got no dates is over see you Monday
morning nice and early stay black
have a great weekend stay healthy stay
home and mind your business you don't
know [__] nothing
you don't want no immigrants outside
your door talking either kick this
[__] mealy
[Music]